there's lots of amazing weather
phenomenon happening all over our planet
but what's going on outside of our
atmosphere my name is Leland Melvin and
as an astronaut I can tell you weather
conditions in space can be a matter of
life and death especially during the
tres4 when we prepare for a spacewalk we
have to be able to deal with
temperatures that range from positive to
an activity degrees Fahrenheit in the
Sun and minus 250 degrees in the shade
but in our spacesuit we have the ability
to withstand those temperature extremes
because the advisors it reflects the Sun
away from our eyes and we have heated
gloves as well as the heated suit and
then we have cooling that allows us to
stay cool during those temperatures
range
a solar flare is a sudden flash of
brightness observed near the sun's
surface that emits x-ray and UV
radiation in space the radiation levels
can be deadly when we're notified of a
solar flare on the space station we
retreat to what we call the doghouse
this doghouse is lined with water baths
that allow us to block the radiation
coming from the Sun before it gets to
our body and that's where we go to keep
from getting exposed to high-energy
radiation and we go further out into our
solar system weather events become more
and more extreme Jupiter our solar
system's biggest planet also features
its most impressive storm the Great Red
Spot
the gigantic tempest is twice as wide as
planet Earth and has winds that reach up
to 400 miles per hour it's been swirling
over Jupiter for at least 150 years
[Music]
further out Neptune features its own
great big storm it takes up the planet's
entire atmosphere Neptune is our solar
system's windiest planet with wind
speeds that can reach up to 1500 miles
per hour that's 9 times faster than the
strongest winds ever recorded on earth
to find the strongest known winds in our
universe we have to go well beyond our
solar system astrophysicist at York
University have discovered the fastest
winds ever recorded near a supermassive
black hole these wind speeds clock in at
125 million miles per hour
I hope my crew never gets caught up in
anything like that
[Music]
you